we turn to Jim Newell a staff writer at
Slate covering politics Jim good morning
good morning as Errol suggested it may
have been more than just the travel
problems this may go back to actually
the failure to repeal Obamacare yeah I
think that Tom Price was on a very short
leash with President Trump already
because he hadn't been able to get this
through and this may have almost been an
excuse to sort of push him over the line
we also heard Errol mention there were
there are other members of the cabinet
right now where there's some travel in
question Steve nooshin Ryan Zinke what
is the fallout from this well that made
me wonder because once you saw other
stories of other cabinet secretaries
having these same issues it was almost
like you can't just eliminate Tom price
to get rid of the problem so maybe he
wouldn't get rid of anyone but now we're
gonna see how long this goes you you we
did see yesterday afternoon Mick
Mulvaney the head of the Office of
Management budget issued a memo saying
that this was no longer allowed you know
everyone must fly commercial no matter
how senior you are Jim you wrote that
that speaking of Obamacare that the
Obamacare repeal will never die what did
you mean what I meant was that a 7-year
promise doesn't just go away you know I
mean it's foundational to the identity
of the party right now so we've done you
know five or six times it seems a
process has gone through they're gonna
try this again after tax reform you
mentioned tax reform that's where the
focus has sort of shifted we saw so much
infighting when it came to Obamacare
within the Republican Party do you
expect this to pass easily or are we in
for more of the same nothing's ever easy
I mean we're in for more of the same the
question is I think that they recognize
they have to get something done here
because the failure to repeal Obamacare
for now at least has really hurt them
with their base so they know that they
just have to sort of will this thing
over the finish line but it won't be
easy I mean every tax break that you
eliminate has an army of lobbyists
behind us can they do it without having
Democratic support they can do it
mathematically it just makes it much
harder you can only lose like two
senators you can lose about 10 percent
of your your ranks in the house so it
will make it a lot harder to do it on
along party lines but if you tried to
get Democrats that's always a risky
opportunity and you would probably have
to change the legislation in ways that a
lot of people in the Republican caucus
would have problems with the president
has talked about trying to do this with
bipartisan support
possibly reaching out though so I mean
what's that what's the possibility of
that there do you think well he has done
a couple of rallies he's gone to the
state he's gone to Indiana where he did
a rally with Democratic Senator Joe
Donnelly he did one in North Dakota with
Heidi Heitkamp so I think he would very
much like it especially since he gets
pretty good headlines when he works on a
bipartisan basis
I think congressional Republicans are a
little less sure they think that
Democrats will just try to squeeze them
on this we also we saw some of this
bipartisan love I would say when Steve
Scalise came back this week can we
expect maybe a little better working
together keeping in mind all that he has
gone through and they have gone through
I think that that may just be a nice
moment I you know well even when he was
shot it's sad to say they said if a note
a wonderful loan from this and it it
didn't seem to be yeah you know it's
just the same structural factors in the
same polarization that produces the
gridlock is still there I mean hopefully
this just reminds members that doesn't
always need to be quite so personal we
appreciate it Jim Newell with the very
latest thank you thank you and tomorrow
morning on Face the Nation here on CBS
John Dickerson goes one-on-one with
House Speaker Paul Ryan he will also
speak with Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer and CBS News contributor Bob
Schieffer